we are told drag the sliders and then
they say which slider creates a scale
copy of the shape or which slider
creates scale copies of the shape
so let's just see explore this a little
bit okay that's pretty neat these
sliders seem to change the shape in some
way and in different ways
so shape b right over here so it starts
off it looks like the width is a little
bit bigger than the height i'm just
trying to eyeball it we don't know the
exact numbers and so in order to create
a scaled copy you'd want to scale the
width you'd want to scale this bottom
side and the top side and all of the
sides you would want to scale by the
same factor
but as we move this slider it seems like
it's only scaling the width it's not
scaling the height
so this slider shape b right over here
the slider for shape b is not creating
scale copies of itself it's only
increasing the width not the height
while shape a it looks like it is
increasing both the width and the height
so that would be a scaled copy so for
example that looks like a scaled copy of
this which looks like a scaled copy of
that which was our original shape
that is not a scaled copy of this
let's do another example
so once again they say drag the sliders
and they say which slider creates a
scale copy of the shape all right let's
get shape a
so this does look like we're scaling
down but we're scaling both the width
and the height by the same factor so
shape this shape a slider does look like
it's creating scale copies of the shape
b right over here well now we're only
scaling it looks like we're only scaling
the height but not the width so this is
not creating scale copies of our
original shape it's elongating it it's
it's increasing its height but not the
width